[Music]
if you guys are all getting straight
a-pluses and then you did a test and
they ended up getting bonus points for
that test would you be generous and give
it to another student how do you point
to another person I was like eight plus
plus plus plus
that's my I don't know how loud but
probably I would be [ __ ] be [ __ ] down
I'm so done that needs help in here
especially if someone was like
borderline failing or like borderline
between like a D and a C or a seen it
are they my friend yeah but if we're
getting a pluses I mean and that means
people are pretty [ __ ] down around
exactly come on I'm like how am i how am
I getting highest grazing it you know I
could beg to differ
oh I smash that's crazy I think I need
another jacket I just got hit up by the
ice man I'll protect you see if you can
add some more shoulder pads that
conscious about my shoulders - yeah good
good good so maybe create insecurities
[Music]
is three weeks from now you're somewhere
exotic apart and you like bark - my
shoulders are good cuz like she doesn't
want to wear bikinis anymore because
she's like I don't want my shoulders to
be shown yeah let me look at it
I've been told by a lot of people that
have very sexy very sexy they get me
hard yeah your shoulders get a hard-on
mm-hmm almost all the kind of guy so
joke's on you Iceman I guess so yeah I'm
really feeling the show okay history
teacher for 11th grade shared this photo
I'm feeling that [ __ ] for sure it says
if you could can you give my bonus
points to whoever scores the low you
teachers a pass this whole Diddy must
score that high
bonus points does this [ __ ] have 8 +
94 and Bush usually gets a pleasant oh
but he failed this one
I thought someone like a basketball
player scored 12 points in the game like
get my point that's like oh we dislike
call me when you put up 60 he's like
give some to the other game you scored
12 points alright so the teacher wrote
on Facebook this caption have to shout
this out had honestly never seen this
one of my guys a straight A plus guy
offers up his five bonus points to
someone in need anyone
totally offering up what is rightfully
his his earning to any peer that may
have been struggling especially hard in
the day of the test he's getting plagued
by I'm sexist and then he said he didn't
care if if he considered them a friend
didn't care if they were cool then it
mattered to him what situation had
caused them to score lower he just
wanted to help I know right shouldn't
like give it to the hottest chick in the
front or he could have been like who
needs help
cuz I could help you could help me in
other ways and I can help you this way
or I could help you learn yep what I
know yep so did you minute but no that's
wack just give them the results right
hey I get straight A's pay me 20 bucks I
mean he I could tutor your [ __ ]
dumbass you just be a nice guy you know
but this is janky news I gotta make this
go for 12 and a half minutes okay just
be like hey I agree with this guy what
am i how old is he how old is he
hopefully let me grade he ain't been
nice he's a junior in high school you
telling me you were he was a third
grader I'll be like that's a sweet
[ __ ] little boy man nice 11th graders
are [ __ ] that's what I'm saying so
he's not he's got something going on
there he's trying to [ __ ] the teacher
he's trying [ __ ] I know I'm saying he's
a [ __ ] communist
yeah you don't think
there's gay communist boisterous there's
gay commie
I think both communists are gay sake you
want to [ __ ] that well yeah I mean okay
there you go teacher he's good-looking
he doesn't see how he's getting played
when I was a junior in high school I
need to maybe like five guys like that
points I have to take I remember I
failed history twice really you were
bored that you were causing a ruckus
because you're so smart
I did in the oil it was easy like the
first quarter and then I wouldn't I
would fail all the other ones cuz I lost
is boring well that [ __ ] is easy in
elementary school but in high school
that's just not easy yeah my teachers in
high school got pissed they would always
get mad at me cuz they always gave me
the like I'm smart but I'm [ __ ]
around too much speech so like I
remember geometry was my [ __ ] I killed
geometry [ __ ] a B is congruent to BC
and all that boy shake when you fell you
should be a teacher with that kind of
[ __ ] dication of wait I want to hear
Gio's joke please well yeah what did the
Acorn say when it fell off the tree that
makes sense but this is what that they
told it to punch like it maybe you want
to take my own life
no okay why gee I'm a tree Oh Cass cute
wait what gee how much because there
wasn't he all but you but I physical
Steve this money must silence for that
one I think I got it I think I got it
when I was really bad at algebra I had
that they had like split up algebra it's
like two different some I didn't take
like the the dumb kids algebra because
like for the people just could be they
had to skip the first semester into two
different semesters yeah cuz I just
couldn't get it I was so bad at algebra
my teacher quit teaching and [ __ ] got
a house book that's how bad I wasn't
because at you yeah [ __ ] yeah I was
horrible at everybody I don't know even
like four times I know a geology joke ok
alright what did one rock say to the
other rock geology nah let's rock nah
don't take me for granted you know what
delivery is everything that's everything
you gave up on it yeah and that's why
you got that
I'm learning I'm learning thank you
okay I just thought of another watch the
delivery watch him very carefully what
did one rock what did one rock say to
the other arm are you rock don't smoke
me fool how do you know if I liked it
but I like that delivery was on point I
don't know um speaking of jokes in my
geometry teacher we told her this riddle
one time she was like she was she was
from Spain and she was really funny
accent his name was um Mis Mis espana
nice yeah I forget mrs. Manion yeah we
told this riddle and you were like okay
miss miss espana right a horse rides
into a town on Friday
stays three days and leaves on Friday
how is that possible right and then so
she's so logical you don't say in
geometry and this is congruent to this
she's like okay I think I have an answer
I should it was it was weird because she
was Spanish but she had a weird accident
I think I have a Spencer right so she
was like okay so I think maybe when you
crossed into this hemisphere the time
difference is blah blah blah were like
Oh miss royal look miss royal the
horse's name is Friday
just oh she got all frustrated shut
bring in time zones a [ __ ] yeah I used
to see a question and be like it's like
one train is moving towards this area at
this speed and the next train is moving
towards this area at this speed what
time I Dre I'm raising my hand and my
teacher comes over and I make excuse me
teacher this is very boring yeah I'm
surprised it it'll beat you ready okay
what did the big tomatoes say to the
little tomato oh I know what did they
say
you got a mustard ketchup
delivery bark cut you off he heckled it
it could have been great
yeah he had called he had so much
potential we were all right there but
was it my father was it's always this
one yeah he heckled you but he mustered
up the strength oh that's really good
thank you though but and you know why
the big tomato got pregnant she didn't
know what a condom man oh thank you I'm
gonna relish that man you're in a pickle
broth anyway back to the story so then
it turns out that horseradish his he
gave his extra five points to help a
student who had 58 points so then with
his five points she was able to pass
yeah she was very great I don't like
this [ __ ] you know why it makes me feel
like he's this superior creature that's
like here's these dumb books that can't
even get points yes I'm [ __ ] worthy
my scraps cuts
you can't even [ __ ] study and work
for it like me cuz you're so stupid
I need these points just take it you
know what it is cuz he's going for prom
king
so they everyone's gonna be like oh man
is Darrell smart but he's generous I
think he's really nice for nothing in
return
so all you gotta do is give [ __ ] to
people and you're automatically nice
that's why all the celebrities give
stuff for their own PR they give a [ __ ]
about any of those what do you think
Oprah is the most loved woman in the
whole country cuz you get a car you get
sugar so much showbiz Ellen Ellen took a
page out of her butt easy for me to do
you gave us alcohol we're like
but we do the people we care about
though yeah but it said Joe Hall dude
just go into Auto Workers you
disease-like
take down the Union to unionize this
place you guys don't need to compete for
your wages that's what I'm saying I'm
trying to help people out that way yeah
if they don't see it as kindness I'm
trying to help people empower their
companies by it smashing the unions up
lower their wages take away their health
care and they look at me like the bad
guy I don't know why I'm so
misunderstood and I can say that forever
you know it's another take that a lot of
people are taking with this story is
that they're saying they're like I don't
like this teacher why did you let him do
this now you're teaching that girl that
couldn't pass the test then she just
could take other people's work and then
succeed that's not a life lesson teaches
her to wait for charity frankly it
teaches her the old and methods the
olden days tick tick tick tick tick one
time big dick it's not like it's gonna
be a regular ass occurring he said in
his 12 years of teaching he's never seen
anyone do that
yeah now this kid's gonna go down in the
history books you don't probably don't
even know the history books how many
people can even the healthy people even
think of hey I got points extra can I
give it to someone that's like so next
level you don't I like about this though
is that this guy he's like hey I'm gonna
give it to whoever as scores Louis he's
not like give him to Brett I think we
all know that was the teachers point to
in his caption when he was saying it he
was like he didn't care to be popular he
didn't care to impress a girl like you
just like give it to our nieces oh it's
so giving and he's like you know what
I'll do I'll call the news and I'll tell
the news yeah I got a try I know I like
giving though it's fun when you go to
stories but then everyone's gonna take
no I want to take take take take
they didn't give give give give give so
there's a take move gift move will you
give music all the time I like that yeah
and you know what I see through the
[ __ ] mother
what you see right now I see us and we
just hit 350 million views dad drink to
that
[Music]